good news for all you Bundesliga fans  around the globe the long wait is  finally over the new season is starting  and our kickoff prediction competition  is back it's easy to take part choose  your language log on and start picking  your scores like Andre from Sao Paulo he  won the big prize and is flying with his  wife to the opening game of the season  in Munich oh yeah hello my name is Andre  I'm 25 years old and a big fan of German  football and FC Bayern by  a little tune here on the kickoff  website I was a champion in predicting  scores last season can you beat that  every match they win against a DVD of  our award-winning final trilogy from  kickoff who will be smiling this season  only the real pros can redic twitch  teams will shine this time round sign in  and start predicting good luck you're  watching the policy more goals more  action on DW